i have to do this you know i i i have no
choice but to do this i don't want to do
it i have to do it
we have another video of some
middle-aged liberal woman on tick-tock
singing a song that she made up um this
one about the stimulus package
and every time i play this stuff on the
show people get mad at me
and i want you to know i have no choice
you know i feel that it's my obligation
or at least if i
have suffered through this then i i feel
as though for your own good you should
as well
i hope that makes it better but here's
the song listen
look at this stuff isn't it neat
competent leaders getting us back on our
feet
the american rescue plan it has
almost everything
a year into this mess recovery unfolds
how many wonders can one rescue plants a
little mermaid i think right reading hit
over you'd think really i know my disney
phone no republicans
voted for this thing it's got direct
relief to american
families it's got a path to reopen
our schools cost of child care
tax credits baby it's like they care
it's a big deal mental illness is a
serious problem there's
more
don't you imagine the neighbors the
people looking out their window and
seeing this happening
wanna go out dancing having convos with
those
what are they called again oh yeah
friends okay some turns off turn this
off
turn it off who put this on
my gosh and who there's someone behind
the camera who is behind who is doing
this
to this poor disturbed woman
like someone in that family i don't know
if it's the husband or a child
it's probably one of the kids you know
whoever it is your mo your mother comes
to you and says uh listen i wrote this
song about the stimulus package
uh it's kind of uh it's based on a
little mermaid so i wanted to perform it
uh and then put it online will you will
you film
if you love your mother there's no way
you say yes to that
no you you go you you take her to
therapy you take her to counseling
you say mom listen i know it's been a
tough time there are people who can help
you let's get in the car let's go talk
to some people okay
it's gonna be fine we don't need to do
this
that's who i'm angry with i am angry at
the family members who allow these women
to do this
if you have a middle-aged woman in your
in in your family
this is what and she wants to to make a
tick tock video with a song she made up
under no cert maybe pretend you're
filming if she really insists
take out the phone and say okay mom go
ahead wow this is a great song yeah i'll
post this online
oh my goodness listen hit that subscribe
button
right now do it right now i thank you
for your compliance
it is somewhat appreciated